أعتقد أن الرسالة التي
سأعطيها للأجيال القادمة هي أن العلم متاح
للجميع ونأمل أن يكون السفر عبر الفضاء متاحًا
للجميع
عندما نحتاج إلى الإعلان عن أنهم
يبحثون عن مرشح يعاني من إعاقة جسدية
أعتقد أنها كانت فرصة ملهمة
ومبهجة.  ونظرت إلى
مواصفات الشخص واعتقدت أن
هذا أمر طموح حقًا ،
إنه أمر شجاع للغاية وجريء جدًا
للقيام بعمل
جيد بالطبع أن تكون رائد فضاء هو
شيء حصري للغاية ولكن وجود
إعاقة لا ينبغي أن يحكمك
كان ذلك حقًا جزءًا من هذا
المشروع الخاص جدًا الذي أطلقناه
أه ومع
خلفيتي العلمية الواسعة ومجموعة واسعة من الخبرات
شعرت أنني مضطر لمحاولة مساعدته في
الإجابة على هذا السؤال ، هل يمكننا جعل شخص
يعاني من إعاقة جسدية يقوم
بعمل هادف في  space
[موسيقى]
كنت متحمسًا بشكل لا يصدق وأنا
فخور بنفسي لأنني مررت
بعملية الاختيار ، فقد كانت
تجربة رائعة جدًا ومنحت
بصفتي مبتورًا لم أفكر مطلقًا في أن أكون
رائد فضاء كان احتمالًا ،
لذا كانت الإثارة عاطفة كبيرة
وأنا أتطلع إلى ما يخبئه المستقبل